i thought we talked about the laws of
thermodynamics and maybe the second law
in particular so there are four laws
uh there are laws one to three and then
there's law zero which i suspect was
slotted in after the first three laws
um and it's actually sort of in some
sense also the most trivial album which
is why it's the probably called the
zeroth law so the zeroth law just
basically says if you've got three
bodies call them a b and c
if a and b are in thermal equilibrium
with each other which is just a fancy
word saying they're the same temperature
which means if you put them together no
heat flows from one to the other so if a
and b are in thermal equilibrium and if
a and c are in thermal equilibrium then
b and c will be in thermal equilibrium
it does seem fairly obvious it's it's a
kind of a formal way of saying really
there is only one definition of
temperature and that there is no way you
can actually come up with a system where
temperature is defined in a funny way
such that one of these bodies has some
peculiar properties such that its
temperature as far as body a is
concerned is one thing but its
temperature as far as body c is
concerned is another thing and i think
because it is sort of stating the
obvious i think that's why it's the
zeroth law so the first law is also
fairly obvious in that it's basically a
sort of restatement of the conservation
of energy in thermodynamics there's kind
of two sorts of energy there's useful
energy which is work so that's when you
if you push something or whatever that's
you know that's sort of applying energy
to it and that's useful energy and then
there's useless energy which is heat
and what the first law says is that if
you've got a body
and
you apply a certain amount of work to it
so that's one sort of energy and then
you add a certain amount of heat to it
the total energy of that body will be
whatever it was to start with plus the
energy you added from the work plus the
energy you added from the heat
so it's really just a statement of the
conservation of energy really so i mean
there are kind of obvious laws but you
have to start with the basic building
blocks into order to build up the entire
subject of thermodynamics and these are
really the most fundamental building
blocks the third is difficult to talk
about until we introduce a concept of a
thing called entropy which is to do with
the disorder of a system and the third
law is basically saying that as you call
a system down towards absolute zero the
degree of disorder so this quantity
entropy drops towards zero or at least
drops to a very low value so classically
it will drop to zero there are some
sorts of systems it'll just drop to a
low value but it will decrease
until you get to absolute zero and then
it'll stop so the second law
um has has various formulations the
first formulations were put together
really before this idea of entropy and
disorder was invented
and they were very kind of operational
definitions of it so there were two
classical statements of the second law
of thermodynamics the first is one due
to a guy called clausius
who said that
heat
won't
travel from our cold body to a hot body
and that's sort of trivially known if
you've just got a hot body and a cold
body and you put them in contact with
each other the heat will flow from the
hot thing to the cold thing so they'll
end up at the same temperature they'll
meet somewhere in the middle and so it's
kind of obvious if you're just doing you
know putting things in contact with each
other but his statement is stronger than
that which is there is nothing you can
do
to make
heat flow from a cold body to a hot body
without putting some work in
so if you're prepared to inject some
energy you can make
hot things colder
and cold things hotter um and uh so you
know a fridge is an example where you
pump heat out of something which is
already cold and add it to the air which
is warmer so fridges you know in some
sense they violate the purest view of
this view of this law that you can't get
heat to travel from something cold to
something hot um but the get out is but
you're putting work in so you're allowed
to do it so if you've just got an
isolated system you can't do it it's a
one-way street and there's no way around
it is the important point that no no
matter how clever a machine you come up
with you can never make it so it will
extract the heat from the colder thing
and add it to the hotter thing without
having to put some work in along the way
so that was klaus's statement and then
this uh the other statement and that's
that's in some sense that's a sort of
physicist statement because that's about
you know heat flow and observations of
what happens when you put bodies in
contact with each other the the second
version of this is due to lord kelvin
and kelvin's statement is more of an
engineer's statement this comes back to
this fact that there are these two sorts
of energy this kind of useful energy
that you can do work with
and there's useless energy heat that you
can't really do work with directly and
kelvin's statement basically says that
you can't turn heat directly into work
you can't just take heat and turn it
into into useful energy
now of course again you do this as steam
engine for example takes heat and turns
it into work
but in order to do that you have to have
waste heat left over so his statement is
that you can't again have a kind of
sealed box where you just put heat in at
the top and the only thing that comes
out is work you're always going to have
to have heat going in work coming out
but then some waste heat coming out as
well there is a fundamental limit as to
how little the amount of waste heat
there is that you can get out of it and
you can figure out what that limit is
but but it's always a finite amount you
can't you can never reduce that to some
you know completely infinitesimal or
zero level those two things sound like
completely different statements right
they're talking about completely
different things but it turns out
they're exactly equivalent to one
another and i can show you if you like
so the way we're going to do this is by
saying if
one of these versions of the second law
isn't true then the other one isn't true
either
so let's assume
let's violate clausius's statement of
the second law which basically says you
can't get heat to flow from the cold
body to the hot body so let's assume we
have a magic fridge which violates that
law
by actually allowing us to suck energy
out of the cold body
put it into the hot body without
actually having to plug the fridge into
the mains okay
and then on the over here i'm going to
just have a
an engine like a steam engine or
something which doesn't violate any of
the laws at all and i'm going to take an
amount of energy out of this hot body u2
and because this isn't breaking any laws
there has to be some waste heat from it
so we'll set it up so that amount of
waste heat is actually equal to q1
keeping lord kelvin happy so yes exactly
that's not violating any of the laws and
we're going to get some work out of this
which is just the difference between
those two this is the first law again
that says that you have to conserve
energy overall so if we've got q2
flowing in and then the amount of work
we get out of there is just the
difference between the two now the neat
part here is that what we've managed
effectively to do if i just draw a box
around
this little lot here
and so that's just going to be i'm going
to stick all that on in a box and i'm
not going to care what's inside that box
and what that box is actually doing is
it's taking an amount of energy with how
much energy is coming in it's taking
heat out of this body
and it's taking an amount well there's
q2 flowing out and q1 flying back in so
the amount of energy that's coming out
of this hot body is q2 minus q1
and this box then the only thing that's
coming out of it is work
q2 minus q1
so this now violates
kelvin's version of the second law
because
actually we what we've all we've done in
this process is we've taken an amount of
heat out of this hot body and turned it
directly into work and kelvin's
statement of the lord says you can't do
that professor that shouldn't be a
surprise because we built the box by
breaking the rules we just broke
clausius as wording of the rules exactly
but what we're trying to show is that
those two statements of the second law
are the same as each other they're
really stating the same law
and so indeed if they are the same law
you'd expect if you broke one version of
the law you'd break the other version of
the law as well but if they're actually
different laws or they're stating
different things then that wouldn't
necessarily be the case but that's kind
of halfway there that shows that if we
violate klaus's version then we're
violating kelvin's version but to really
show their equivalent we've also got to
show if we violate kelvin's version
we're also violating clausius's version
okay okay so kelvin's version of the law
says that you can't just turn energy
into work so you can't just take
heat and turn it directly into work that
has to be a by-product so let's violate
that by coming up with a magical engine
which directly turns energy turns heat
into work an engine which yeah which
does nothing but take this useless
energy heat and turn it directly into
useful energy work an infinitely
efficient steam engine so a real steam
engine would be waste heat coming out
the bottom but we're violating kelvin's
law here so we don't have to do that
okay okay and then we're going to take
that work
and we're going to use it to power a
fridge
okay and that fridge will because this
is now a proper fridge it's not
violating clausius's law or anything we
can get it to work so we plugged it into
the mains and we can actually
use it to suck
energy
q2 out
so we can figure out how much uh heat's
going to come out the other end it's
just going to be the two lots of energy
going in there's q1 and q2 so now if we
just put a box around all this lock
and say this is this is now my magic
machine
and i don't really want to look inside
the box i just want to know what it's
doing
what's happening it's sucking an amount
of energy q2 out of the cold
and then on the hot side you've got q1
coming out and q1 plus q2 going in so
the net amount of energy flowing into
the height is q2 so effectively we
created a machine here where with
nothing you know no extra external wires
or anything within that box it takes an
amount of heat q2 from a cold body and
adds it to a hot body and that violates
klaus is this version of the second law
so what we've shown is that if kelvin's
version of the second law isn't true
then clause's version isn't true and if
clausius's version of the second law
isn't true then kelvin's version is the
second law isn't true
and so just to kind of finish it off so
we've got these two laws
kelvin's version and klaus is this
version and the sort of four
possibilities they might both not be
true
one might be true and the other one
might be false
or the other way around
or they both might be true
and what we've ruled out by showing this
is we've shown that if kelvin's law is
of his false thing then clausius has to
be false too so it can't be true
if klaus is his version of the law is
false then kelvins
can't be true it has to be false as well
so we ruled out those two in the middle
so the only two possibilities is they're
either both wrong or they're both right
and that's just another way of saying
that they're saying exactly the same
thing we haven't been able to prove that
they're true but we've shown that if
they if one of them is true the other is
true and if one of them is false the
other one's false in other words they're
kind of equivalent to each other
nicely lined up which will keep it in an
orbit basically following
following the earth around there used to
be lots of science fiction stories about
l3 it used to be a popular place to put
the anti-earth or you know if you're an
evil genius that's where you put your
hidden layer